imagine if earth suddenly lost
an entire continent
north america wouldn't just vanish off
the face of the planet of course
instead it would sink into the oceans
what could cause this chain of
unfortunate events
how long would it take for the continent
to go down
and how would this change the rest of
the world
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if north america sank into the oceans
one billion years ago the continents
meshed together into one
super continent called rodinia
but don't mistake it for pangaea
that came long after
during the era of rodinia the
continental crust
that forms the continents was at its
thickest
from that point on it began to slowly
erode
and sink at this rate of erosion
some 2 billion years from now the
continents
will be fully submerged once again
i'm not ready to wait that long so what
do you say
we speed things up for north america a
little
okay how exactly would this work
well remember what i just said about
rodinia and continental crust thickness
that's right the continents are
shrinking and sinking
in our scenario it would just happen
much faster to north america
the half billion people that live in
north america
would lose their homes they'd have to
move out to
another continent but since events were
unfolding so fast the airlines would be
unable to cope with so many passengers a
lot of people would be left behind
and go down with the continent and those
who were lucky enough to flee
would cause a refugee crisis worldwide
but that would just be the beginning
you might know that continents don't
just float in the ocean
they sit on the layer of solid rock
known as
the upper mantle this upper mantle
and the earth's outermost layer the
crust are broken
into tectonic plates and
north america just happens to sit on one
of them
if the continent was to submerge it
would have to do with the north american
tectonic plate
going down and this is where the bad
news would start
the sinking of one tectonic plate would
shift
other plates around this would trigger
anything from
tsunamis and earthquakes to volcanic
eruptions
they might be massive enough to wipe out
humanity altogether
at the same time the sea level would
rise significantly
this would flood other areas of the
world displacing
even more people and destroying more
communities
and it wouldn't help that parts of north
america are covered with ice
all that ice would float and then melt
adding to the effects of climate change
if you were still alive you'd have to
invest in some
powerful air conditioning because it
would get very hot
very quickly
the countless volcanoes and other
natural disasters unleashed by north
america's
bold move would make it tough to
continue farming
so i hope you like canned food
and maybe you might want to go live
underground until the
earth cooled off a bit but
that's a story for another what if
you